a lot can happen in a three-hour long
movie and plenty did an Avengers endgame
heartfelt emotion genuinely hilarious
dialogue and the life-or-death mission
that Earth's Mightiest Heroes embarked
on Avengers endgame had it all and
executed everything magnificently
and it kept intensity high until the
very end when it gave a fan-favorite
character a soul stirring send-off and
teased the introduction of a new hero to
take his place let's break down exactly
what happened major spoilers ahead
Thanos barely had time to snap his
fingers in Avengers infinity war before
fans began wondering what would happen
in Avengers endgame specifically which
dusted characters would return from the
dead and which surviving heroes would
meet there and forget but the common
name on everyone's list of heroes who
would likely die in Avengers endgame was
no doubt Captain America speculation
heated up even further when Captain
America actor Chris Evans reiterated
that he would be retiring from the role
of Steve Rogers after endgame it pains
us to say it but Captain America did
make a stupid shirt drawing Avengers
endgame rather than get crushed by
Thanos or sacrificed himself to protect
his fellow Avengers Steve Rogers lives
through to the end then chooses to go
back in time by himself and return the
Infinity stones to the places in time
the heroes took them from professor Hulk
explains that even though only five
seconds will pass in their time Steve
can spend as long as he wants in the
past and that's exactly what he does
Rogers returns as an elderly man clearly
at the very end of his life after
returning the six Infinity stones to
their rightful places cap chose to
remain in the past reunite with his one
true love Peggy Carter and grow old with
her Steve tells all this to Sam and then
does something big he tells him to try
on the Captain America shield and see
how it fits though Falcon admits that it
feels foreign like it will always belong
to someone else
Steve makes it clear that he wants Sam
to be the new Captain America so what
does this mean for the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it seems all
but guaranteed that Sam will someone no
longer be known as Falcon and will
instead protect the world as the new
Captain America considering such a
switch chip as roots and the Marvel
Comics there is more than enough
information at hand for Marvel bigwigs
to feature Sam as Captain America and
upcoming movies it also helps that Sam
Wilson actor Anthony Mackie is still
under contract with Marvel granted he's
fulfilled a standard deal for six movies
but the actor did previously say that he
penned the deal for as he puts it like
50 films
as he told vulture I signed up for as
many movies as I could I was willing to
go as far as they would let me in
whatever capacity they wanted to retain
me Steve passing his shield on to Sam at
the end of Avengers endgame but also
have an effect on the Disney Plus
limited series Falcon and Winter Soldier
starring sebastian stan and anthony
mackie Walt Disney Studios and Marvel
Studios did previously announced the
show's title and logo which are unlikely
to change but after what took place at
endgame it stands to reason that the
title characters could end up working
together as a Captain America duo that
would be a great team can you move you
seen them no they were both present when
old man Steve explained his decision and
of both operated as Captain America in
the comics so perhaps Bucky and Sam were
wanted unite and honor the legacy of the
Steve they knew as a star-spangled
Avenger then again maybe Sam won't take
up the Captain America suit and shield
and will be content continuing to save
lives as Falcon anything can happen in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as both
infinity war and endgame so clearly
taught us so for now it seems all
theories about a new Captain America
post endgame a fair play check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]